la récente publication par l'opposant
russe alexeï navalni d'une conversation
sens et impliquer les services de
sécurité russes dans son supposé
empoisonnement mais de nouveau en
lumière le média britannique bel incat
la vanille a en effet affirmé avoir
obtenu le numéro de téléphone de l'agent
du fsb constantine candrian seif via
belinga tu es dans la vidéo de la
conversation est présent cristaux gros
zf journaliste enquêteur au sein de ce
média béline cats se présente comme un
média d'investigation citoyens qui
produit des enquêtes en ligne sur une
variété de sujets grâce à des méthodes
open source
la réalité est en fait bien plus
complexe l'origine le financement est
les partenariats de belinga de fonder en
2014 par elliot rigging sont plus que
flou elliott rigging originaire de
leicester au royaume uni a occupé un
poste à responsabilité au sein du
département digital de l'atlantique car
ce l'influent think tank qui entretient
des relations étroites avec l'otan il a
rédigé plusieurs rapports dans la droite
ligne des positions de think tank
notamment sur la syrie où ils
recommandaient aux états unis de frapper
damas pointant notamment du doigt
l'utilisation supposée de barils
d'explosifs par l'armée de bachar al
assad et analysant l'impact des frappes
aériennes au moyen de sources ouvertes
et plus tard au sein de belline cat
il a activement participé à la campagne
médiatique et des puissances
occidentales
accusant le président syrien d'être
responsable de l'attaqué chimiques de
ran cheyrou oui mais y'a aucun rapport à
le très indépendant bely cats s'est
également penché sur le crash du hem h
17 en octobre 2015 en désignant un
coupable avant même la publication de
l'anc est officiel se basant sur des
vidéos youtube et des photos partagées
sur les réseaux sociaux
beijing 4 n'a pas hésité à accuser la
méchante russie et les forces anti
gouvernementales du donbass d'avoir
abattu l'avion dans l'est de l'ukraine
pour ce qui est de son financement nulle
mention n'est faite sur le site officiel
quant aux relations étroites entre bel
incat le ministère britannique des
affaires étrangères et du commonwealth
higgins a publiquement nié que béline 4
et reçu des fonds en provenance du goût
en nommant britannique mais en même
temps ce média indépendant se tape
d'être en partenariat avec l'open une
formation par chip oubliant de préciser
au passage que cet organisme est lui
même entièrement financé par le
commonwealth et selon le travail très
documentée du journaliste qui déclarent
une belle qui s'appuie sur des documents
rendus publics par le groupe de hackers
anonymous l'oapi se résumerait de fait à
une usine de désinformation dont le rôle
tiendrait davantage à la gestion de la
narration sur des sujets chers au
gouvernement britannique
l'oip ses soutiens et whitehall n'a
aucun intérêt pour la transparence la
démocratie la vérité l'exactitude
l'égalité ou la paix en réalité ils
cherchent à opérer dans l'ombre
déformant la perception du public pour
correspondre aux intérêts financiers
politique militaire et idéologique de la
grande bretagne en utilisant la
manipulation la distorsion
l'endoctrinement la diffamation la
propagande et le mensonge
voilà donc un sacré partenaires et pour
cette affaire avec la vanille alors on
peut vraiment comme ça en un clin d'oeil
pour quelques centaines d'euros
obtenir les données d' agent du fsb qui
vont tout raconté par téléphone
le piratage de données revendus sur le
marché noir ça existe nombre de
journalistes font un large travail
d'investigation là dessus comme dans la
sphère skripal le journaliste de la bbc
mark cuban qui avait collaboré avec
bellingham sur la sphère skripal
confiait en 2018 à la radio et demi si
ces chercheurs indépendants qui ont
identifié ces personnes est pointé du
doigt leur appartenance ogm rue se sont
largement appuyés sur des bases de
données piratées qui piratent ses bases
de données et leur transmet je pense
qu'il s'agit du gchq ou de la msa
dans une interview accordée au média
mais 12 à bellingham ne fait par
ailleurs pas mystère de la vocation de
son travail qui vise à pousser à
l'ouverture d'une enquête que ce soit en
russie ou ailleurs en europe
nous espérons que quelqu'un se chargera
d'une enquête officielle que l'allemagne
par exemple décidera d'ouvrir une
procédure et de l'instruire notre niveau
d'activisme minimes
nous croyons qu'il existe une vérité est
qu'en personne officiellement né c'est
de trouver les empoisonneurs notre
activisme conduit à essayer de pousser
les allemands les britanniques
n'importe qui a enquêté sur cette
affaire de manière officielle
à partir de maintenant nous n'aurons
plus de grand rôle à jouer
bon bah y'a plus qu'à 1